er wollte was geht ab jetzt willkommen
bei einem neuen video ja ich wurde in
letzter zeit ziemlich oft geprägt von
anderen youtube und unter anderem auch
zu dem guten morgen tag den ich heute
ganz gerne mal für euch machen würde
damit ihr wieder so ein bisschen mehr
über mich mal und zwar habe ich tolga
vom kanal toll dass er zu diesem tag
getagt der link zu sagen kann als auch
in der infobox ich wünsche euch viel
spaß unter vertrag
ja und natürlich mal sagen von herrn mit
frage nummer eins und zwar lautet diese
was für ein wetter hast du also wenn ich
mir den wecker stellen dann nehme ich
immer mein handy aber ansonsten so zur
schulzeit oder so weckt mich meistens
meine mutter nächste frage hast du einen
user also wirklich was nutzer ist könnt
ihr euch das beantworten aber ich gucke
mal als ich herausgefunden 10 sa ist ein
wecker mit weckfunktion durch radio oder
ein akustisches signal mit ansage der
weckzeit snooze funktion fünf minuten
nach dem ersten wegkommen wurde und so
weiter also nee hab ich nicht oder nein
habe ich nicht
sie meine freundin hat zwei drittel
frage und zwar was machst du als erstes
wenn du aufwachst ganz klar egal ob's
wochen eine sonderschule ich gucke mal
direkt auf mein handy das ganz witzig
weil das lied immer nachts auf dann 34
und von meinem bett weil es liegt immer
daumen und dann gucke ich da drauf und
dann blendet das so dann wird man ein
bisschen mehr machen kannst du das
kaffee oder tee also ehrlich gesagt ich
trinke einen kaffee also morgens trinke
ich keinen kaffee und kein tee und
abends trinke ich höchstens manchmal
thema aber sehr selten café manche
irgendwie nicht schläfst du mit fenster
auf oder fenster zu ja sie kann das so
bestimmen wenn es neue zimmer mega warm
ist dann macht ihr das fenster auf und
schlaft und ein und das wetter immer
noch auch bunter mix draußen kalt und
wenn neue zimmer auch automatisch kalt
und dann kriegt eine erkältung also das
würde mir schon ein paar mal so
ansonsten ganz wirklich ziemlich warm
ist schlafe ich gerne mit offenem
fenster aber jetzt es ist ja nicht so
waren deshalb lieber mit fenster zu
irgendwie besser duschen also morgens
vor der schule durch die eigentlich nie
höchstens ab und zu oder eigentlich
immer wochenende wenn ich aufstehe dann
du sie auch aber vor der schule habe ich
da einfach überhaupt keine zeit zu sonst
würde
jetzt mal zu spät kommt weil ich halt
erst so kurz vor der schule bevor die
überhaupt anfängt auch stirb du nicht
kleidung schon rausgesucht
ja das ist meistens so also ich trage
jetzt nicht jeden tag unbedingt ein
anderes outfit sondern dann habe ich
immer meine hose und so im badezimmer
liegen und denke mir habt ihr einfach
ein anderes t-shirt heute an um den tag
der haut sie ist in eine rosa und so das
variiert dann immer also dann rede ich
halt erst ins badezimmer und sie den
ersten teil meiner klamotten an dann
wenn ich zu mir zurück ins zimmer und
den rest bis sicherheit fertig angezogen
bin christin patino reden aber das sind
nur noch fünf fragen frühstück süß oder
herzhaft muster der unterschied
ich esse man nur süßlicher sind teller
egal was nutella und orangensaft das
war's schon und wurst brot oder brötchen
ist eigentlich immer unterschiedliche
fernseher radio oder stille ok am
wochenende wenn ich auf der kuppe ich
manchmal fernsehen wenn ich frühstücke
aber ansonsten habe ich keine zeit um
radio zu hören oder so dann stehst du
auf ja ich glaube das habe ich schon
ziemlich oft beantwortet also wenn
schulzeit ist stehe ich immer um viertel
nach sieben auf meine schule beginnen um
8 uhr und am wochenende immer so
zwischen halb elf und eins oder bisschen
später laune
ja das kommt ganz auf den tag an also
morgens nehme montagmorgens ist immer
über scheiße genauso wie sonntagmorgens
weil ich dann weiß am nächsten tag in
der schule ansonsten ist sie immer ganz
variierend sage ich mal
samstag ist immer cool freitags auch
meistens sonst geht so und dann zum
schluss auch die letzte frage fragen wir
mal zurück und zwar wie schläfst du ich
schlafe immer unterschiedlich manchmal
da schlafe ich so in die eine richtung
ein und wacht dann in die andere
richtung aus kennt ihr das ja oder can
trust your way tun dann sind wir ja
leider schon wieder am ende dieses tags
und ich hoffe natürlich es hat euch über
gefallen und falls ihr bock drauf habe
dass ich jetzt einfach mal so mitten in
der woche hier und da mal einen neuen
tag hochladen
gibt dem video doch einfach mal daumen
nach oben ansonsten schreibt sie die
kommentare oder so auf jeden fall würde
ich sagen aber nicht vergessen
danke für 8000 abonnenten habe ich jetzt
ja auch schon wieder gepackt auf jeden
fall geht das richtig krass ab dafür
recht herzliches dankeschön
und ja am wochenende sonntag kommt
natürlich wieder das haupt video für
diese woche und abonnieren nicht
vergessen wenn ich wenn ihr nichts mehr
verpassen wollt in der beschreibung
instagram und co ansonsten geht es hier
auf der linken seite weiter mit meinem
letzten video das war mit meiner
freundin dinge die du niemals zu deiner
freundin sagen sollst und hier rechts
auf der anderen seite mit meinem letzten
tag lag bei smart würde ich sagen
ansonsten schöne woche noch heute bis
sonntag